[Music]
hi i'm greg and i'm john and uh we're
with the real rejects
uh destin
this is a
freaking honor to be talking with you uh
to put it simply because i'm i'm asian
american myself so this movie shang chi
means more to me than
than uh than a lot of other people out
there
it's really nice yeah
and i'm a white guy so he's a white guy
so i love movies
well i'm both of you i've got a little
of both in me oh perfect we are your son
now i finally am happy to be here
didn't you guys do a reaction video to
one of the trailers i watched that one
oh my god really we don't need any more
fries
yeah
that means so much
about butterflies no one's ever
that means so much uh thank you i know
we only got a limited amount of time
with you so we'll try to be super quick
about this um we thought the movie was
great
absolutely wonderful and uh i grew up on
a lot of jackie chan samo hong yuan meow
along with some like yuan wu ping and
corey ewan films and then knowing brad
allen was involved the inspiration from
what i grew up on was all on display so
i was curious
was there any fight scenes in particular
from any particular movies that you drew
like inspiration from are there any
specific movies that you were
referencing while uh crafting this film
or any particular action sequences
yeah quite i mean uh countless i mean
there are easter eggs all over this
movie not only from the mcu but from
some of our favorite martial arts films
of the past
brad allen and his team
were
so incredibly well versed in
the rich history of martial arts cinema
that they were constantly saying oh we
want to do this move because it's a
updated version of
this scene from whatever and those
constants um
some of i mean people are picking up
already of of some of the jackie chan
influences that are
pretty evident in the bus fight sequence
yeah um i think the the general
storytelling of that fight really
represents
brad allen's background under trained
under jackie chan and and also brad
allen's inspiration from one of his
heroes buster keaton which yes
the king of physical setups and payoffs
and
quirk and humor mixed into into a fight
scene we also had
a choreographer that brad allen brought
on named pong zhang who um he was
actually one of jet li's
stunt doubles and was a wushu champion
himself before he came and came into
cinema he was inspired
um loosely inspired by
jetly's tai chi master um yes yes when
he was
he choreoed along with chris cohen our
one of our brilliant action designers
they they choreo the wenwoo versus lee
fight in the beginning that beautiful
elegant fight
and then combining
that with
a lot of influences from
anime and video games for the last two
uh
wenwu vs sun fights
there were a lot of influences a lot
absolutely loved it i know we only got
like a few seconds left but we got
there's one john why don't you ask this
last yeah let's go with it we got a
couple of them to go with that one so a
lot of times these films obviously
there's a bunch of crossover potential
and you know the heroes have you know
fight scenes sometimes even with each
other like in civil war is there any
marvel character mcu character that
you'd like to see chongqi either team up
with or face off against
um
i mean one obvious answer to that is the
chair you're sitting on
and we were towing around with that idea
in this movie but you never know like
the the creative process is such a
evolving flowing thing at marvel because
everything's happening at one time so
you have to catch it at the right time
for characters to meet together
in it to make sense but the
possibilities are endless
awesome awesome uh i this was uh this is
absolutely amazing this is just made our
day i don't even care about that
spider-man trailer coming out anymore
this is the best part of the day yes uh
thank you so much for your time the film
is wonderful you did a fantastic job and
i can't wait for the sequel thank you so
much thank you thank you take care bye
[Music]